the coronavirus as you know is having a
huge impact on the economy from small
businesses trying to simply make ends
meet to another volatile week for the
markets so here to help us figure out
what it all means for investors and for
all of you at home we have PwC partner
and business development lead Mitch
Rochelle and capitalist Pig comm founder
and editor of a new textbook of
Americanism which I believe is on one of
the many books on the shelf behind him
Fox News contributor Jonathan Hoenig
so Jonathan Mitch guys another just
terrible week I just want to run through
some data points real quick you've got
consumer confidence numbers sunk to a 32
month low unemployment rate jumps to
4.5%
and then those jobs numbers even worse
than expected the initial jobless claims
surging to more than six point six
million more than doubled in the
previous week Mitch which of those data
points jumps out to you as just the the
worst worst the best christen I would
say that the jobless the weekly jobless
claims number because the unemployment
rate that came out yesterday there's a
little bit of a lag there the survey was
done in the middle of the month of March
so the real indicator that I think the
markets looking to and in fact every
American feels it is the jobless claims
number and there's some estimates up
there that are hellacious showing us
week after week we could get to
something like that another five million
another ten million coming down the pike
the reality is this program the Paycheck
protection program that became live
yesterday is intended to stem that tide
and give small businesses which employs
16 million Americans much-needed relief
to get people back on the day roll yeah
well since you brought it up let me just
ask you one more question about those
paycheck protection programs there was I
mean this is a huge program incredibly
complicated it's being rushed to meet
the needs of these
mrs. but the rollout did have its
complications what are you hearing about
how well it's been executed so far the
good news I came with a prop the form is
very simple the rules like anything in
the banking world which is regulated or
complicated I think a lot of scrambling
went on last week and banks were trying
to get the resources pulled together in
their infrastructure pulled together to
accommodate it I think this week
hopefully will be a lot more efficient
for borrowers but everybody the word got
out and borrowers were literally lining
up at banks to get their loans yeah I
mean Kristen access ironically Jonathan
worrisome yes be a process that Mitch
alluded to Luca reminds me a little bit
of the tarp program back during the
global financial crisis with a decade
ago with tarp you got tremendous tarp
fraud at all the malinvestment became
and belong and produced ultimately the
slowest recovery in modern economic
times this comes back to in my mind
getting Americans back to work
I mean look you're right Chris Thomas
those statistics are studying but
stunning but when you quarantine people
you force them to stay in their homes I
mean we're not looking at a recession we
are looking at a Great Depression so we
need to find some way to allow
businesses to be creative yes of course
isolate the vulnerable but perhaps
follow more of the Swedish model which
is not an explicit lock down and letting
creative businesses find some way to
produce even in these is pandemic even
during the pandemic so but Jonathan I
mean we're really only in the beginning
of all of this I mean how bad do you
think it could get if we stay locked
down through the end of this summer well
boy I mean it's how you know how further
down the date the thing I think the
president doesn't understand Kristen is
that the economy isn't like an engine
you can't quickly turn it off and turn
it on and the longer you allow
businesses to run fallow and affected
not stay creative and not try to solve
this problem the longer this system is
going to persist so you know when easy
fix for example if they want to put
money in people's pockets
would be following the Hubert Humphrey
model cut some taxes cut the gas tax for
example allow people who have to be
productive to work to pay that much less
at the pump during this era so find some
creative ways if we continue to shut
down the economy a Great Depression
isn't just a possibility it's a
guarantee yeah and it's really tough
balancing act that President Trump has
been trying to to deal with you know
keeping people safe healthy inside
versus keeping our economy safe and
healthy a really tough decision that
he's having to deal with and then you
have of course some folks who say it's
not a choice it doesn't have to be a
binary choice but at the moment it
certainly seems like that
Mitch Jonathan gotta leave it there
thank you guys so much